all right we are ready to say howdy to
hello kitty as it is set to open a cafe
at the newest location at fashion show
jillian of course joins us with live
with the live look and the pink and all
the treats and the cute dress and the
ears and the sparkles
yes hi rocky i am in pink heaven here at
the hello kitty cafe it's their new
location at fashion show i'm joined with
jill we have jill and jillian so we're
we were meant to meet today so as we all
know out here in las vegas the hello
kitty truck was at park mgm everyone
loved it it was so fun to visit and now
you actually have a storefront tell us a
little bit about this location what
makes it so special yeah no we're super
excited to be bringing our hello kitty
cafe concept here to fashion show las
vegas we saw so much love for the first
location that we wanted to just expand
the experience and bring more things
hello kitty and just give fans a chance
to
you know connect and have fun with kitty
so here we are at fashion show well it's
so fun in here the trees the food
everything looks delicious i found a tea
that matches my outfit so i have to pick
it up but tell us about some of these
menu items that we have in front of us
too so we have um of course like super
cute uh delicious treats um baked fresh
daily locally so um you can come have
your instagram moment plus they're super
delicious to eat um this particular
location we're debuting the waffle cone
and soft-serve ice cream that's only
available here
lots of drinks lemonades teas coffees so
you know whatever your choice is there
lots of options pastries donuts you name
it cake cupcakes we've got it all julie
you're making me hungry and on top of
all of that you guys have some really
fun merchandise here we're taking a look
at that right now some of it is
exclusive here to the fashion show
location as well right yes yeah so we
have a grouping of merchandise um the
pink and white hello kitty chef t-shirts
only available here the pink and black
dad caps there the sprinkle headband
cookie mug and then your sequin plush
they're holding the vegas sign that's
special for this location well this is
any hello kitty fans dream come true
it's my dream come true they have some
specials going on for their grand
opening happening tomorrow and i'm gonna
get behind the counter and try to make
that waffle cone in just a few minutes
so stay tuned and before i let you guys
go of course i have to go for the pink
donut and take a bite so i'll check back
in with you guys soon i'm going for it
jillian you better bring me back one of
those
you know i love donuts okay
i'm eating them all